hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the monday morning podcast for
july
5th [ __ ] 2021.
how's it going how the hell are you
how was your weekend how was your fourth
of july weekend did you have a good time
did you cook some burgers and dogs and
maybe some chicken
and some hogs and some [ __ ] uh some
veal
real cutlets
you have a big bag of potato chips
did you drink too much
did you say that thing you shouldn't
have said but then you said it that
didn't even feel good because everybody
looked at you like you were the [ __ ]
even though you don't think you
are is that how you celebrated
the birth of america happy birthday to
america
happy belated birthday to america
happy belated birthday dear america
i'm very thankful these [ __ ] lunatics
didn't burn down all los angeles
i will tell you you really see the lack
of power
that law enforcement has if everybody
just decides to ignore one law
they just get overrun every year out
here
during um sorry
[ __ ] can't stop yawning you know why
because it's 5 48 in the morning
5 48 in the morning i get to help my
wife with the kids today so i woke up
early i was having stress streams
because i knew i had to knock the
podcast out because i got two other
[ __ ] things i have to do
right and i'm telling my wife you know i
got all this [ __ ] i have to do i see the
look on her face like well what the [ __ ]
i got the kids all day
are you going to be able to help out you
know so i get up
early oh freckles i wasn't done with my
beauty sleep
i wasn't done dreaming i was having all
these [ __ ] up dreams
i think it was the stress of all the
[ __ ] that i had for some reason i owed
i owed people money
and i was driving around like i had a
bookie i had to pay off
and it was weird like i had the money
i had the money but i i couldn't [ __ ]
i couldn't find the guy and then i
finally gave it to the guy
and he opened it up and he and like
marinara sauce went all over his face i
had like a [ __ ] like racist dream
about [ __ ] italians
i owe this italian guy money and he
opened it up and all this [ __ ] pizza
sauce went on his face
and he's looking at me like are you out
of your mind because it was all over the
money too
and i was saying to the guy i was like
dude i don't
i was like i don't give a [ __ ] about
money i just you know i'm sorry i don't
know how
how it got like that none of it made
sense didn't even make sense to me
but it's like i wouldn't try to openly
disrespect you
because i know the [ __ ] you are i don't
i don't know what any of this dream
meant
all right and then there was somebody in
the middle of it somehow
i'm not going to name names there i saw
this other comedian and i owed him money
no i didn't owe him any money i gave him
something
so food he's fancy [ __ ] slid slippers
on
these fancy [ __ ] slippers that were
all monogrammed and all this [ __ ]
and somehow some sauce got on his
slippers so then the mob guy goes i
ain't accepting this [ __ ] money
and by the way you owe so and so some
new [ __ ] slippers
so then i got mad at him and i said
listen
i i know i owe them slippers i was gonna
[ __ ] buy some anyways but not cause
you [ __ ] told me i have to
then i was thinking why am i yelling at
this guy like this this guy's gonna
[ __ ] kill me
and then i woke up
that was the end of the dream i don't
know why there was pizza involved maybe
because i'm on a diet
and i'm trying to lose the weight you
know
well freckles lost his two to three
pounds this past week i'm down to like
you know 186 187 after tipping the
scales at almost [ __ ] 190.
i'm on my way in the other direction
despite the fact everybody's telling me
i look
fine you look great i think you look
fine
i think you look fine i look fine i put
on [ __ ] 15 pounds of chocolate cake i
don't look
fine you have body dysmorphia i hold
myself to a higher standard
jesus [ __ ] christ you think i was
karen carpenter
your face looks better does it with all
that frosting in my cheeks
um so anyway
i did pretty good when i was out in los
angeles it was my first road date
my first road date indoors official ones
i played at the cosmopolitan
i did three shows i had a great time and
i'll tell you what is
really [ __ ] amazing about stand-up
comedy after the last year
and a half of basically not really
leaving
you know los angeles
my act became very regional
i can't say it became regional it just i
just became used to the sound of los
angeles crowds
in the first show friday
that i did um where you go to vegas and
it's a cross section of america
people from all around
waddle on the planes with their tank
tops and their flip-flops
to walk just walk around casinos looking
at [ __ ]
and not really gambling anymore
it's the weirdest thing about vegas now
now it's like you know it used to just
be
right this is where you came out to go
[ __ ] gamble and bring your goomba
so she quit [ __ ] bitching at you you
know
she quit bitching like lewis hamilton
um i don't even see that [ __ ] race i
got i got it taped i'm gonna watch it
today but i guess um
max first step and won again so of
course the [ __ ] story
isn't that max won it's that lewiston
one
didn't win and he's complaining like oh
not fast i mean he is better page
guys are better i mean louis do you
think you can win
no no with the car that we have we're
not
yeah i think they got even faster and
we're not getting faster
oh he's just gonna win and all i have to
do is
you know i'm just competing for second
or third place
it's just like buddy you got your own
[ __ ] private jet it's [ __ ]
it's sick [ __ ] thing is sick it's
[ __ ] this maroonish black it's one of
the sickest [ __ ] planes i've ever
seen in my life
hey what what are you [ __ ] whining
about you win the goddamn championship
every [ __ ] year
i mean how how much does it have to be
tilted in your [ __ ] favor
at the whole [ __ ] i have to have the
best card the most money every [ __ ]
week or else i [ __ ] whine about it
jesus [ __ ] christ these stupid
[ __ ] people in the press like that's
the story
if the story is either he wins or he or
how does he feel that he didn't win
and meanwhile somebody else is winning
the race a guy by the name of max
verstappen who's now has a sizable lead
a sizable lead hey is there any way
everybody who covers racing
could could [ __ ] tell me uh you know
how louis
hamilton feels about being uh
[ __ ] a whopping 18 points behind
let me guess he's not happy about it
156 points to 138 points
all right this is what's [ __ ]
hilarious max verstappen has four wins
he's got three wins so like oh you're
one race behind
well what's what are you [ __ ] crying
about
i don't know i gotta stop reading that
[ __ ] just watch the goddamn races
they always do [ __ ] like that in every
sport they just have
there's the one [ __ ] diva that the
whole [ __ ] thing pivots around
and if they don't win the whole like no
matter what you're just gonna have to
hear from this person
so then what ends up happening you end
up resenting the person
and i maybe it's the press i should be
upset with the [ __ ] press
that they're not covering max verstappen
who's been driving for [ __ ] red bull
all of these goddamn years stuck with
them i didn't hear that guy
[ __ ] moaning and complaining every
[ __ ] week being like oh mercedes benz
has all the [ __ ] money
if i [ __ ] drove for them i [ __ ]
win every [ __ ] race too
i don't hear that'll be [ __ ] weak
i'm not even mad at lewis hamilton i
just didn't get enough sleep last night
i'm trying to [ __ ] plow through this
podcast that's what the [ __ ] problem
is right
i'm talking now um so anyway these um
these people come out there to las vegas
and uh
from all over the country
and the first show i did just the sound
of the crowd was so different than what
i was used to
and the things that made him laugh and
didn't was just
subtly different enough to kind of throw
me off for like the first 10 minutes
you know i was like the hell's going on
it plus
i went out there and i did the worst
thing ever is i made like a
uh i made a setlist
you know which i kind of do
normally but like for some reason it
like put me in my head
rather than trying to flow because i was
trying to mash together
[ __ ] i was doing before the pandemic and
then this [ __ ] afterward
and then i finally figured out that like
dude
just do what you always do go out there
and talk about the newest [ __ ] you have
that's the most exciting to you and then
your [ __ ] will naturally
like weave its way in the old stuff
you'll say something with the new stuff
which will be like
oh that relates to this idea and then
talk about that
and then you'll start flowing so it took
me the whole [ __ ] weekend to figure
out to do that
the shows went great i'm just saying
like i was up there
literally like how the [ __ ] do i do this
again
i don't really remember but um
i don't know i really had a great time
though but i had to kind of remember
i don't know if i ever told you guys
this i do this thing when i walk to the
microphone sometimes
i'm sort of like uh
i don't want to tell you guys because
then you're going to be like [ __ ]
looking at me as i'm doing it i do this
little [ __ ] thing that empties my
brain
that has nothing to do with my act has
nothing to do with the fact that i'm
walking onto a stage
i just [ __ ] you know i whatever i'll
tell you i just i sing a stupid song
that doesn't even [ __ ] exist
it's just dumb and it doesn't make any
[ __ ] sense and i just emptied my
[ __ ] brain
so when i walk up there i'm not thinking
anything
um so then i won't go into robot mode
of like go to anything how is everybody
oh that is fantastic and now here's the
idea that i already knew i was going to
talk about
20 minutes ago when i made this [ __ ]
set list and now i will be way inside
the back of my head
trapped in my act over the next 60 to 90
minutes
so i kind of forgot how to do all of
that [ __ ]
um i worked it all out basically within
the first like 20 minutes of the first
night um and then over the course of the
weekend
sort of the order of things that i
wanted to talk about naturally uh
like fell into place and uh
it was yeah it was just a [ __ ]
amazing weekend i had all these people
come out to see me
friends that i i haven't seen in a while
and uh the only bad thing of the weekend
was i went downstairs
and i wanted to get something to eat
right
and uh they got this hot chicken place
there
all right and i go down there and
there's like a [ __ ]
two-hour line i'm like you gotta be
[ __ ]
kidding me why does every [ __ ] hot
chicken place have like a [ __ ]
hour long line why is that [ __ ] so
goddamn popular
do you know they got this [ __ ] place
out here called howland ray's
all right i remember that place when it
used to be just a food truck
this is back before i was shaving my
head and i would just buzz it down
and i used to buzz it down like once a
week or something like that
to keep it fresh to death so i [ __ ]
i would go over there and the food truck
would just be sitting outside this
[ __ ] barber shop that i went to
like every other week you'd just be
sitting there
and i would just walk up to it maybe
there'd be one other person in line
and i was like this is a [ __ ]
really good chicken sandwich this might
be one of the best chicken sandwiches i
ever had
i told my wife about it we would have
them and we enjoyed it we walked up hey
how are you sir with your freshly buzzed
[ __ ]
cue ball head i saw i am doing fine
what what can we get for you oh i would
like one of these all right well it'll
be this much money well here's your
money
thank you so much and good luck with
your business and then one day they
[ __ ] say to us hey
this is the last week of the food truck
we're actually becoming a brick and
mortar store we're becoming an actual
location i was like oh that's great i'll
look you guys up congratulations i love
seeing stories like that you know you
came from nothing
yeah you [ __ ] murdered some chicken
you put some hot [ __ ] on it and people
liked the way it tasted
and now look at you like al capone going
from the streets to your own little
[ __ ] hideout god bless you i can't
wait to go there so one [ __ ] day
a couple of months in to this store i'm
like hey remember that [ __ ] food
truck neil's like oh boy oh boy do i
i said hey would you like to go i
[ __ ] love to get a chicken sandwich
i'd go over there
it was like there was like a [ __ ]
line i can't even describe how
long this [ __ ] line was
well of course i can describe it here we
go it went out the [ __ ] restaurant
door
down the street through like a seating
area because it was a whole [ __ ]
area i believe where there was other
places where you could get [ __ ] to eat
it went through that back out the food
court area
onto the sidewalk and all the way down
the [ __ ] street
and i was just like well [ __ ] it
that's what i do at all of these i
haven't had a hot chicken sandwich i
can't remember
since
there's just nothing worth standing in
line [ __ ] two hours for i'm not doing
it
i'll go across the street to a [ __ ]
denny's
with a bunch of old people sitting in it
and get some stupid-ass grand slam
breakfast before i'm gonna [ __ ] stand
in line
but too [ __ ] after the better part of
a [ __ ] day for a goddamn sandwich
i just want to say that people in the
line don't you value your time
what are we in a communist country
standing around here for bread this is
america
you get a [ __ ] sandwich before you
can even think that you want a [ __ ]
sandwich
you're standing in this [ __ ] line for
two [ __ ] hours
oh it was so good oh my god it was so
good i really didn't know your feet are
swelled up twice the [ __ ] size you
know what the reality is is i really
wanted that [ __ ] chicken i'm still
[ __ ] thinking about it
maybe i'm just impatient maybe i should
have stood there
i could do some elvis because i was in
vegas
with the [ __ ] flip-flops and a tank
top on
and i would have waited for some chicken
and i would have ate it by myself
the line was so [ __ ] long
i actually called up andrew themless
and i said andrew and he said what i
said i'm gonna do a celebrity thing here
i'm gonna big time this [ __ ] line and
he goes all right what i go i want a
[ __ ] hot chicken sandwich
is there any way i can use whatever
leverage i have
that i'm doing my [ __ ] and dick jokes
upstairs
to bypass this [ __ ] line
and he said hang on he called me back
and he said no you cannot sir
that chicken place has nothing to do
with the casino it is an independent
corporation
and i said fine and then i walked by
this other place where nobody was in
no you know what i did i said [ __ ] this
there's an in and out that's off the
strip it's [ __ ] two and a half blocks
away
i'm just gonna [ __ ] go over there
then i'm thinking what if i walk all the
way over there
with no sunblock on there's a bald
ginger
with a little hat on and i get over
there
and there's more people in flip-flops
and tank tops just lining out the
[ __ ] door
then what am i gonna do
well fortunately
i never had to cross that bridge because
it took me like 20 minutes to figure out
how to get out of the [ __ ] casino
and when i did i i i couldn't get off
these skywalks that just led to other
casinos
so i finally got down to the ground
and i get on the ground and i make i go
around to the left because i know where
the [ __ ] i'm going
and it says the sidewalk is closed and
i'm like jesus christ
i got to walk all the way around the
other side of this [ __ ] casino so i
do
by the time i get to the other side of
the casino it's so [ __ ] hot i just go
back into the thing
it's not back in the [ __ ] casino i
didn't get in and out i don't have a
[ __ ] hot chicken sandwich
i'm still [ __ ] as white as chalk and
i see this [ __ ] lonely maitre d
standing at this [ __ ] you know
restaurant area and i say hey
are you guys open she's like yeah
and i was like all right can i come in
and eat
she's like well you know it's like a
half hour wait and i said
she's like you can sit up at the bar and
i just started walking away it's like i
get it i get it
you're busy i get it
i just [ __ ] walked away
i went upstairs and i realized that i
had an apple
in my backpack
and i just ate that and i just sat there
shaking my [ __ ] head
so then yesterday when i went to go
leave the casino
i was walking out and ended up on the
food floor
and i saw that the hot chicken place was
open and there was nobody in line
but it was like [ __ ] eight in the
morning i was like i don't want a
[ __ ] hot chicken sandwich
but part of me was thinking like you
should just go eat one
because there's no line and then i was
like that's a panic thought i don't make
decisions
in that mindset [ __ ] that chicken
sandwich
so then i come home
in the fourth of july festivities
are getting going and my wife one of the
worst things i ever did
i taught her how to turn on the flattop
grill so now she just takes over
she loves [ __ ] cooking on it she
absolutely
loves the thing after all these years of
giving me [ __ ] for owning the [ __ ]
thing
she now absolutely loves it
she's making [ __ ] burgers and hot
dogs like
you know just completely emasculating me
i mean the grill comes on like i'm
supposed to be [ __ ] doing it
nope she's doing it and all i'm thinking
about is that [ __ ] hot chicken
sandwich that i wanted
oh you know what's even worse is we ran
out of gas halfway through
because she's been cooking on the thing
and because she's been cooking on it
like you know i usually you know reach
down and i go to lift the thing up
if my old ass [ __ ] arm if i can pick
it up and do a curl with it i know we're
getting down to it
but she's been cooking on it like the
last two or three times
and um so she cooked the dogs
you know she did a great job on those
and then she made the burgers i'm
staying around like [ __ ] useless
and she was on the way out going like
hey am i doing these burgers right i'm
like well you know you want the patties
nice and thin you want a three ounce
[ __ ] thing and you want to [ __ ]
have it super hot
that's what you want to do and i get out
there and it's not hot at all
but there's sizzling because there's the
leftover heat and i just sort of peeked
and didn't see a flame i'm like you're
out of gas
it's like i'm out of gas i get you're
out of gas so we had to finish them in
the [ __ ] pan
it was still delicious though still
delicious
delicious delicious so of course today's
my weigh-in
after i ate burgers and dogs but at
least i didn't have that [ __ ] hot
chicken sandwich and i did the
elliptical twice
when i was out you know both days i went
to the gym
you know threw the weights around a
little bit
and i really miss going to the gym but i
want to thank the cosmopolitan casino
okay except for that [ __ ] hot chicken
sandwich place
um i had such a great time all the
people that showed up all the people
that have been holding onto the tickets
that they had since before the pandemic
i could not have had a better time um
and actually i was actually you know
happy in a way that the uh
that the chicken place had the long line
because i actually got out and walked
around the strip a little bit before it
was too [ __ ] hot and i had to go back
in
and it was like can't remember the last
time i walked around in vegas
you know after a while i was just like
because those casinos are so big and
they're so difficult to figure out how
to get out of there
you know like i i had to like when i got
out
off the elevator when i was downstairs
trying to find the chicken place
i like was doing like the hansel and
gretel thing with the bread crumbs
i was like making mental notes
of what is where so i could get back to
the elevator
and then even then i think i got a
little bit lost for like half a second
you know it might have been hot chicken
[ __ ] rage but anyway
i worked out there with uh richter leah
and aldusha
who does the voice of anthony on f is
for family and he was closing with
that bit you know what you know what
which is the bit that we saw him do and
that's how we ended up on the show and i
got such a [ __ ] kick out of here in
the crowd
you know that you know he killed all
week as did rich
uh rich jesus christ as did rick
and um he [ __ ]
uh in the end he would close with it and
just to hear people like
freaking out like oh [ __ ] that's the guy
that does the voice
on the show you know it's such a surreal
feeling
when you see [ __ ] like that it took me
back to a long long
long long time ago i did
bonnaroo it's mainly a music festival in
nashville tennessee
and um they had stand-up comedy in an
air-conditioned tent
so i went to go see this band
that had brain on drums and i want to
say less clay pool was in it
and i remember the lights went down
and this was the early 2000s and i was
on chappelle show
and the lights went down and i just
heard this guy
way over on one side of the crowd go
what and then somebody else yelled out
yeah and then somebody else from
somewhere else went
okay and i was like
i got like chills it's like holy [ __ ]
like that's when i realized that the uh
all of these people were watching the
ship i knew everybody was watching it
but like
to just have it validated like that i
kind of you know this is a much smaller
scale than how big the chapel show was
but was that feeling again
of like yeah i mean i know you know
we're in our fifth season obviously
people are watching efforts for family
but it was really cool every night
i made sure every night i was up there
when he was doing the bit so i could
hear it so
um and then it just so happened that
a bunch of people that i knew and loved
were in town
and uh i had a little balcony
on my room and uh they all came over to
the hotel
and we all just [ __ ] hung out all of
these comics
just hung out on friday night because i
only had one show
so i had a big hang friday night back at
my room and we just sat there
[ __ ] talking [ __ ] and telling stories
laughing our asses off smoking cigars
and all that [ __ ] and just had a [ __ ]
great great time um so
it's good to be back and uh i was also
happy that you know
thankful for all the [ __ ] people out
here that during the pandemic
started all of these rooms you know
started you know the at the magic castle
the jam in the van
all of these places that i did the
supernova
all of these places that i was able to
keep my act where it needed to be so i
didn't go out there and embarrass myself
so there you go so that's what ended up
happening
and other than that i was out there by
myself
and um i think i facetimed my kids like
[ __ ]
at least five times um
and i was fighting off the depression of
missing them as much as i did but then
on the other side i was like really
happy that i did miss him
you know so like all right i'm [ __ ]
normal
because i didn't you know that would be
a bad thing if i was just out there like
ah
jesus finally some [ __ ] me time
um and also rick the great rich little
the guy who taught me how to do the
the letterman show by watching him when
he was on david letterman i never met
him
but uh he was at the aladdin and he had
a 6
30 show and i was really tempted to walk
over there
and watch it but i just didn't know you
know i assumed it was sold out or
whatever i didn't know how to get
tickets or anything so
um that is one of those things when i
get to vegas there's always like a few
legends out there the last time like
donnie marie were out there and they
were wrapping up this show
at the flamingo and i was like man i
gotta
i gotta see them i used to watch them
when i was a kid on the donning
donnie marie show um
one of these days i'm just gonna go out
there what are we one of these days i
got two kids i'm never gonna do it
but i want to just go out there and just
go see
like i would love to do it see donnie
marie then go see rich little and just
go
see these people live you know
before they uh retire or whatever
because i feel like that's the last time
donnie marie were gonna do that thing
you know at this point they're in their
60s
they still like each other they're
probably like well why push it you know
what happens if we have that big [ __ ]
fight that's been brewing since 1970
whatever
um all right
what the [ __ ] i wrote you know i wrote
this thing down asking this guy
to retell it wisconsin
the [ __ ] does that mean
retell what oh speaking of wisconsin
though
speaking of wisconsin you're milwaukee
bucks
minus giannis
andre davizioso contempora
uh are in the finals against the phoenix
suns
that's [ __ ] fantastic both pylon
teams had
injuries so they couldn't win it
all which is great the phoenix suns
i don't know that they've ever won a
title
if they did it would have to be all the
way back in the 70s i think they no they
went to the finals
the nba finals that's the plural one
stanley cup final
is singular um
they played the celtics dave cowans when
we won in 74-76 there was some classic
like triple overtime game
that the celtics won i think that's the
last time they were in the finals
i mean that's unbelievable i hope
giannis comes back though
um let's see here
phoenix suns your
phoenix suns let's see i gotta look it
up here
wiki wikipedia duda here we go phoenix
suns
i don't think they have any titles zero
championships conference titles they
went in 76 that's right
then charles barkley they went 93 lost
to the bulls they lost the celtics in 76
they lost to the [ __ ]
um chicago bulls
in 1993 now they're in there in 2001
and what do you notice about all of
those
oh no that's wrong the math is wrong it
took him 18 years
between 76 and 93. right
no it's not 18 that's 17. yeah there
goes the theory
i thought it was 18 and then 18 years
again and i was like no it's 18 and then
28 years nope it's 17 years
and now 28 years
huh all right well that's interesting
milwaukee bucks i believe the last time
they even
went to the finals was 1971
when they had a man named lou al cinder
who was a great center so after he's
after a while he's like well i'm a great
center
i have to leave my team and go play for
the lakers
and get them some championships because
that's what are they going to do draft
somebody good
they don't know how to do that i'm
[ __ ] with you
[ __ ] with you um they got one
championship 1971 conference title oh
71-74 they lost the celtics to 74.
and now 2021 jesus christ they almost
went 50 years
yeah because i mean it's such an easy
thing to do because you had uh
you know you had the celtics and lakers
dominance and then the [ __ ] pistons
and then it was the bulls decade
and then the spurs won five and the
lakers bought you know another four or
five
then miami bought like two or three
celtics bought one warriors bought one
or two
yeah there's a lot of people out there
just throwing their [ __ ] money around
like the kardashians
actually they get this [ __ ] for free
don't they and all of a sudden that's
just it
the [ __ ] it just goes flying by look
at the nhl
i mean look at it stand back and look at
it they're adding a new team i mean out
in the [ __ ] uh
seattle it's going to be a smashing
success now there's going to be 32
[ __ ] hockey teams in the nhl
they started off with i don't know how
many then the depression came
and they went down to six
and then it was six from like whatever
the depression was at 1927 28 29
whenever the [ __ ] that was
for like 40 years to 1967.
he had the expansion six then they went
to twelve they added a couple two three
more teams left the capitals the
islanders and that [ __ ] in the 70s
then they got some from the ihl then
they gradually you know they got up to
like 26
28 [ __ ] teams then they're like well
we got to have 30 teams because every
other [ __ ]
you know major uh sports
i don't know professional sports uh
league has 30 teams
now they're up to 32 just like the nfl
so i think the nfl is going to be like
wait a minute we're supposed to have the
most teams
and next thing you know like
albuquerque's going to have a [ __ ]
nfl team
um so what i'm saying is
is that the the droughts
okay are going to become significantly
longer and i'm calling it right now
it won't happen in my lifetime but
somebody is going to go uh
longer than than than the chicago cubs
between championships
because there's just going to be so many
[ __ ] teams
all right especially in the nba if
you're just going to continue to have
these [ __ ] pylon teams
and i don't want to hear it from you
[ __ ] pile on team loving [ __ ] out
there who's like well you look at you
bill you said brooklyn
and the [ __ ] legs when you get to
find the only reason why they didn't get
there is because their superstars got
hurt they didn't get hurt they would
have [ __ ]
been there you know it and i know it so
don't come at me
with your [ __ ] your little [ __ ]
tweets on the twitter there because i
don't give a [ __ ] because uh
cause i like being right there what do
you think about that
i don't care what you think about that
your [ __ ] tampa bay lightning
are up three games to none
and i was really enjoying them beating
the [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of the montreal canadiens but then i
found out they're 18 million over the
salary cap because evidently they found
a [ __ ] loophole
where they put some guy in injured
reserve and then he came back
so uh the canadians do not have any
ability whatsoever
to stop um tampa
from spending 18 million over the salary
cap to go back to back
which is great the people at tampa they
need that
they absolutely need it i mean if you
look at people in montreal people in
montreal look like they're doing fine
except for the drug addicts and the
homeless people there but other than
that if you look at the average person
walking around
you know they're bilingual
they have nice they have a they have a a
good sense of who they are you go to
tampa oh
oh jesus christ
i mean it's just i don't know what it is
down there
it's it's just a city that time forgot
all right everybody's down there like
you you walk around tampa and it's like
is
everybody on their way to a cookout
that's
sorry i'm just [ __ ] i'm just [ __ ]
dude because i know that
that when tampa wins they're going to
start calling tampa title time
which is going to annoy me considering
we had to [ __ ] win for 20 straight
years
across all of our sports all right we
didn't just go back-to-back winning cups
and winning one lousy [ __ ] super bowl
but i guess that's how it is i guess
that's how it is
um i'm [ __ ] with you i'm excited for
tampa all right
very few people respect you
you know nobody goes holy [ __ ] i'm going
to florida oh yeah
where you going miami beach anna
better i'm going to tampa
i mean most people think the name of the
city is tampa bay
because all your teams are called tampa
bay this
tampa bay that tampa bay buccaneers
tampa bay lightning tampa bay [ __ ]
rays howling rays hot chicken [ __ ]
rays tampa bay race they used to be
called the devil rays
you know but people down there are so
goddamn religious
that they don't believe in doctors in
modern medicine
but they think if the baseball team has
devil in it
that somehow they're going to become
possessed if they go to the game this is
what you're dealing with these people
need championships
they're frightened all right they're
scared of doctors
tampa can i ask you a question what is
it about intelligence that frightens you
so much
you know why can't you be like me when
you meet somebody smarter you know
you'll argue i'll i'll do one lap
i'll i'll challenge once and then just
be like all right all right i get it
you're smarter than me
you know it's over i understand it
um by the way uh i kind of uh
stumbled upon this band called the bar
case
which uh i didn't know was otis
redding's
the original ones was his uh the band
that
you know his backing band is that what
you call it and unfortunately
oh that's what asking this guy to retell
it wisconsin was about
when otis reading died in that plane
crash
most of the bar case the original band
died
um with him and there was one guy that
survived a trumpet player
so um
you know having a pilot's license i want
to find out what happened it sounded
like they got a
you know because of the weather
conditions they got ice on their wings
then they couldn't stay airborne because
what happens people
what happens when you get ice on the
wing it changes the shape of the airfoil
so it can no longer do the job it also
adds weight
and it adds drag
all right and if it becomes significant
there's a tipping point where you then
can no longer stay airborne
at which point you are [ __ ] what kills
me is they they made two attempts to
land the first time the guy was too high
and the second time he was too low
is what how this guy was telling it he
went around three times
um which i find hard to believe with the
amount of hours that guy had
he would have known his airport he would
have known the elevation before he went
there
if he did a couple of missed approaches
i would think that it was
you know instrument conditions
what i'm learning is basically when you
get to the decision altitude
or the uh what is it the minimum descent
altitude or whatever
you hold that or you immediately execute
a [ __ ]
missed approach just depending if it's a
precision or non-precision approach
jesus [ __ ] christ i got to take this
test
um so i think he missed it twice
and then when he came around the last
time to try and get it
uh i think that that's what happened i
don't know i don't know what happened
was [ __ ]
horrific um
so i wanted to find out what happened
just so i don't get into that situation
so
i looked up the guy to see him
talk about the you know the plane crash
all these years later and he's standing
in front of a crowd
and at first it's like okay is there
something wrong with this guy
you know because he's really old down i
was worried you know there's something
going on with his brain or something
then i realized it was actually still
hard for him to talk about it
and people are sitting there in the
crowd going you know we he's like
we were in uh the guy in the back's gone
wisconsin
like people like myself are so selfish
they want to hear this story
and they're not realizing like these
were this guy's friends
this was this horrible traumatic thing
and then just like uh the plane started
breaking up
and it's just like i was like i have to
shut this off
i'm not gonna watch this guy doing this
[ __ ] um
so anyway there's this band called the
bar case that uh
basically had happened to the same thing
that happened to like leonard skinner
but like
90 of the whole band was wiped out
amazing band i downloaded some of their
stuff
and they kind of seamlessly went from
the 60s right through disco
um and into the 80s writing hits
and they had to get all new personnel
and stuff and i was really
enjoying a lot of that music see what i
[ __ ] downloaded
and then i downloaded uh a uh
max roach album protest album from the
early 80s i'm
sorry early 60s because this woman sings
on it i was blown away by her voice
i downloaded one other one i forget what
but um i think by watching all of these
movies in the 70s
these obscure movies has got me into
like getting to into more obscure music
because i was oh i've always been
you know mainstream marty over here
where i was just uh mainstream mikey
was probably a better one um yeah
like when i got into aerosmith i just
bought greatest hits and i was fine with
that
but one of my buddies he was the one
that started buying the albums
and bought like toys in the attic and
rocks and get your wings and i was
listening i was like oh [ __ ] this
they have other good songs because i was
just like well if this is their greatest
hits
these are their greatest songs and i'm
fighting with music
it's not about the greatest hits it's
about those other ones
so i've been getting into that and uh
yeah just kind of having a good good
[ __ ] time but i am so once again i
can't tell you guys
i felt like i dreamed this weekend how
much fun i had
doing stand-up again and uh
and just listening to the crowd and
people heckling
the whole [ __ ] experience was just
awesome so thank you to everybody
uh for coming out i really appreciate it
all right and with that
let's read and it's also nice to be on
the road and to get lonely because you
got something to come home to
you know for all you comedians out there
if you're doing what i did we're
thinking like oh i gotta [ __ ] get
i gotta get to this [ __ ] level first
or i'll say well
then i can start a family you know you
don't need to do that
you know if you have a [ __ ] family
you get married
you're gonna work even harder uh it's
one of the big myths in stand-up comedy
uh if you get married have a family
you're [ __ ] and you know as we sit
there and watch
ray romano and all the success that he's
had
and he started a family and uh
it just added to him as a performer
um and the stuff that he could talk
about on
uh everybody loves raymond all right
roman everybody
most guys have tried different ways to
last longer but thinking about baseball
doesn't always work
the folks at roman and online men's
health company are changing the game
with roman swipes the secret to longer
lasting sex
roman swipes are a clinically proven way
to last
longer in bed they're effective easy to
use and fast acting
but don't require a prescription
all right roman can ship swipes to you
in a discrete unmarked package
packaging
of course it is
you don't want the mailman standing
outside your house cop [ __ ] his pants
like [ __ ] what's his face in pulpa
greenwich village going
this guy comes too fast hey
oh coming too fast over here it [ __ ]
ate maple drive uh like so just
great uh unmarked packaging or maybe the
[ __ ] uh
male person busts a nut too quick and
they're going to swipe your package
that's a federal offense you know but
people will re
resist that or numbers and they'll block
that out they'll risk that
rather than you know the embarrassment
of the other [ __ ] so this is why they
exist all right unmarked packaging and
each swipes packages small enough to
hide in your wallet
for whatever you need swipes are great
they will not transfer to your partner
so you can last longer without worrying
they're super easy to use just take the
swipes out of the packet swipe it on let
it dry and you're good to go that's it
go to getroman.com burr and get ten
dollars
uh off your first order of swipes plus
free
two-day shipping that's getroman.com
for ten dollars off your first order of
swipes plus free
two-day shipping i wonder why that
is you know
that it's just so much easier for a guy
to get there than a woman
i wonder why that is
it doesn't make any [ __ ] sense
you know but i know that it's on the guy
you know it they they blame guys
you know that when it takes a woman that
long it's like well you can't satisfy
her
and you know if it was the other way
around it'd be like well you know
women are just more in touch with their
bodies
ladies get your [ __ ] head in the game
jesus christ it already takes you long
enough to get ready
we're always [ __ ] waiting for you all
right simply safe when simply safe home
security's founders
chad and eleanor larrance lawrence
decided their first designed their first
security system jesus bill
in their kitchen they did it for a very
personal reason
their friends had just had their home
broken into
look at that necessity the mother of
invention and they did it in the kitchen
this is like some old school
american stuff they were struggling to
find a security system
sorry that was simple to set up and
would make them feel
safe again oh yeah if your friends
had their house broken into you're gonna
be freaking out like am i next
making people feel safe is what simply
safe has been doing ever since
that moment 15 years ago well how smart
are chad and lauren eleanor
lawrence
i mean i'm not smart enough to design a
alarm system
i would have done what every dumb person
does duh i need to get a gun
and not learn how to use it properly
um not saying that everybody who gets a
gun doesn't know how to use it i'm just
saying that's what i would do
you get the gun first and then be like
oh i'm gonna take some courses
you know it's like when you get a new
video game you know do you [ __ ] read
the instructions on how to play no you
just start playing the game go what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] this is how you do it
all right a passion to protect people
not only drives every engineering detail
in his products
but it motivates every interaction with
its customers
and the thing is simply safe
sorry guys sorry for the yawning i know
i'm making you yawn
but you know i had to get up early to do
this okay
these are my i have excuses just like
lewis hamilton
and the thing is simply safe just makes
it so easy
not once did he say max verstappen is a
[ __ ] great driver
uh it takes about two minutes to
customize his system on their website
simplysafe.com
i s a f [ __ ] e
simply safe has highly trained security
experts ready whenever you need them
is there someone in the house cause i'm
coming over whenever this that where
whether it's that's during a fire
a burglary a medical emergency
or even i used the swipes and my dick
wasn't numb enough
um or even just when you're setting up
the system
there's always someone there who has
your back to keep you safe and make sure
that you
feel safe to learn more about how simply
safe can protect you and your family
visit simplysafe.com
today to customize your system and get a
free security camera
you also get a 60-day risk-free trial so
there's nothing to lose
that's simply safe dot com slash burr
um all right
oh wait a minute i didn't even look at
the [ __ ] questions for this week
now what the hell am i thinking here
you know i brought this [ __ ] up before
this is something i
i wanted to talk to you about i was
watching last night
because i went down this rabbit hole
and uh of uh johnny carson's
and i ended up uh
seeing dudley moore on the show which
reminded me
of um sorry i'm trying to look this [ __ ]
up here
how they used to they make these comedy
albums whether they do these two
characters um
god damn it what the [ __ ] is the name
i don't see whales that was a bit
it was like everything in comedy yet
derek and clive
and they went to these studios and they
just [ __ ] improvised these [ __ ]
albums
they're absolutely brilliant they are
completely 100
unfiltered they are absolute [ __ ]
masterpieces
and what i also love about them is it
shows how comedians improvise
where actors and all these people are
always just like you're not doing it
right
it's yes and whatever i say you agree
with it
okay and comedians don't do that
comedians improvise with no
[ __ ] you and if you watch in in in the
improv world they act like it doesn't
work well
re listen to these [ __ ] albums
because it does
it does they
disprove that theory every three seconds
on these [ __ ] albums
and um
what i
love about these albums is when you
watch these things this is
everything that non-funny
[ __ ] people are trying to get rid of
in comedy
they're trying to get rid of the like
the level of brilliance in this
and and these [ __ ] idiots who have no
goddamn sense not only no
sense of humor and not only lack talent
okay they don't even understand comedy
they don't even understand what the [ __ ]
it is that they're criticizing
they don't understand that like
i don't know what did we even even begin
this [ __ ] subject like say when any
anytime anything bad happens if there's
a tragedy and a comedian has a joke
they're so [ __ ] ignorant of comedy
that they take it as
oh he made a joke because he doesn't
care because he's happy that
he's not taking it seriously when it's a
lot of it's the exact opposite
it's because you do care that's the
reason why there's gallows humor you
have gallows [ __ ] humor
because what you're seeing is so [ __ ]
overwhelmingly emotionally
you don't want to feel the pain that you
make a joke
to give yourself a break from it and
these [ __ ] mouth-breathing morons are
like
how could you say that it said
don't even know what the [ __ ] they're
criticizing
so if you want to just see completely
unfiltered [ __ ] comedy i would watch
uh the prince of wales
derek and clive and then there's the one
uh song dudley moore sings
uh hit the deck broke his [ __ ] neck
there was no blanket laugh we nearly
shut you gotta [ __ ] hear that one
it's about a guy there's like a house
fire and these guys [ __ ]
he's freaking out because he doesn't
want to burn to death and these guys are
on the ground saying hey jump into this
[ __ ] blanket
so the guy jumps and he [ __ ] hits the
ground because there was no
there was no blanket and he dies and
then the guys who pretended there was a
blanket are just laughing their asses
off
and i guess when dudley moore then
made it as a hollywood superstar and
became box office boy as i call it
he was terrified that these albums were
going to come out
and they were going to ruin his career
because even back then
there's just always dumb [ __ ] people
that don't understand comedy belong
beyond
knock knock who's there um
and i cannot tell you even though um
i didn't discover these these albums
until
i was like 10 years into my career
it was something that i was naturally
trying to progress towards
which i haven't gotten there yet it's
just to be completely totally 100
unfiltered so you can try to tap into
whatever talent you have because you
have to just you got to [ __ ]
open the spigot right and um
i was naturally going in that direction
because every comic
that i loved was doing that on stage
back before there was all of these
[ __ ] cameras and social media and all
of this [ __ ]
where now all of these [ __ ] people
who aren't
really that funny want stand-up comedy
graded on a curve
and they want all of these people that
are way way more talented
and way more brilliant than they are to
to
paint between the same within the
boundaries of their own [ __ ] lack of
talent
and that's basically what it is because
you can't just sit back you have an
inability to sit back
and and accept your talent level and
realize
that there's going to be people better
than you and let them be better than you
so then they can show you where the new
bar is which will
bring you up and you'll actually get
better
which is why i always try to watch
people that are better than me
it's [ __ ] basic can you imagine like
in music if they did that
that off all the intermedia intermediate
guitar players
found great guitar players offensive and
told them that they were not allowed to
play the guitar
beyond the level of their intermediate
level that's what the [ __ ] they're doing
with comedy i feel
that's my own [ __ ] opinion i'm
sticking with it and i'll never get off
this argument or that the [ __ ] nba
piling on teams are [ __ ] stupid
all right with that with that let me try
to get to some of your questions here
see if i have the time if i have
if i michael schechner group that's
another one that i [ __ ] downloaded
stumbled upon that one where it was uh
metal music before it had makeup and
hairspray
and it's just [ __ ]
um oh here we go great emails
okay salads
dear billy cabbage hips i wish i had
cabbage hips i have frosted face
um if you're trying to lose weight be
careful of complex salads some
vegetables aren't meant to go together
with things like quinoa
brown rice or in your case quinoa
you [ __ ] just kidding always look into
it oh [ __ ] you give me the answers man
some healthy salads can slow digestion
don't want my favorite comedian to look
or feel bloated go [ __ ] yourself
all right hey eating a salad
you eating a salad to try and lose
weight hey just to let you know some of
those
actually don't work well which one which
ones
which ones don't work sorry gotta go
look it up sometime if i didn't know
better i'd say you're trolling me
all right girlfriend pissed at me for
her selfishness
uh oh jesus dear billy
gynecomastia look it up all right i'll
look it up
there's some doctor laughing right now
gina comastia
is a condition of overdealt
[Laughter]
oh my god you intellectual [ __ ] you is a
condition of over development
or enlargement of the breast tissue in
men or boys
the breasts become larger they may grow
unevenly
often happens when a preteen or teenage
boy is going through hormonal changes or
puberty oh that's [ __ ] terrible
somebody have to go through that um
all right but now you know what i
[ __ ] lost my questions where the [ __ ]
are they
now i have to click on every window all
right girl
okay okay so you just called billy billy
fat tits
you know medic gynecomastia all right i
recent got into an argument with my
girlfriend over a vacation pitch i made
we've been dating for over a year and
are both medical students look at you
guys
rolling in the dough but do you have
time to see anybody
you see each other and uh they want to
practice in montana or colorado when we
finish school
i asked her if she wanted to go on a
week-long vacation to colorado this week
winter in order to see what it's like
she's been twice before and i've never
been
she replies with well you don't like
skiing as much as i do
and if we're not going to be skiing
every day then i don't think it's worth
the money for me to go
she's also rich as [ __ ] so money is not
an issue i told her we can go skiing
three out of five days
we're there but there's plenty more to
do besides that like
breweries snowshoeing snowmobiles etc
well that sounds fun you go to the
brewery right
then you go snowshoeing hammered
you [ __ ] you know work off the booze
weight then you get on a snowmobile and
you ride home
anyways he goes silly me for thinking
that being a compromising person was a
good idea
because she hit me with that's not
something i want to do
so i'm not going so i replied okay sorry
i even asked
she proceeded to say no need to have an
attitude
buddy i'm going to stop right here and
remind you
of how many women out there would love
to be married to a doctor
this chick is the way you're i mean
granted this is just your side of the
story
this chick is a [ __ ] nightmare
um anyway and i i would like to revoke
her medical license because she's
too [ __ ] up her own ass and she's
going to be taking care of people
anyway and all a medical degree is going
to do to this person is make her even
more arrogant
anyway and then when i tried to change
the subject to something else she got
mad at me saying that i shouldn't be mad
at her
now she's been ignoring me for two days
because i asked her to go
on a colorado vacation with me and do
multiple activities instead of just
yeah one thing the [ __ ] thing she
wants to do in the meantime i've talked
to my buddies
and the five of us are going to go
instead whoa
oh oh hey you know what
you got balls i don't get too mad at
that you're like christopher right now
hey tommy why don't you go [ __ ] yourself
that's what you just said that's exactly
what you need to do with a [ __ ] woman
like that well go [ __ ] yourself i'll go
with my friends
anyway so she can just sit at home and
be surprised when my instagram posts
are me and the boys having cold ones in
boulder
love the podcast and can't wait to see
you in atlanta
uh in october ah is there anything
better than self-esteem
and before i get trashed by the women
out here is if a guy did that to you
that's exactly what the [ __ ] you should
do
this is how you set up a healthy [ __ ]
relationship
okay you made a suggestion
she said she didn't want to do it
because of this this and this
you offered a compromise not only did
she not want to do it she act like a
[ __ ] child
so what did you do did you sit there and
be hostage
to her [ __ ] own goddamn emotions you
said no [ __ ] it
and you're gonna go anyway and you know
what that's gonna do that's gonna make
her
either grow the [ __ ] up or break up with
you
which is perfect she's either gonna
become an adult
and realize that she was in the [ __ ]
wrong and he's not be such a [ __ ]
baby
or she's gonna leave you and you can go
find somebody
a woman that is an adult
who doesn't want to go to colorado i
want to go to colorado and go to the go
to the [ __ ]
that hotel where they shot the shining i
didn't realize it was only an hour and a
half northwest
of denver i'm gonna go check that thing
out
stand outside of and just yell wendy
all right overrated
hey build blurry eyes i'm writing to you
from london
where there's even a more boring version
of baseball
and that is cricket i like cricket
i like those games what everybody
everything has to be so [ __ ] fast
just sit around and [ __ ] watch it
have a good time
shoot this [ __ ] with your friends anyway
to be fair i moved
i moved here about a year ago from
eastern europe so i didn't grow up
watching cricket
and rugby but i but basketball and
football handball etc basically
everything that has the word ball in the
name
my best experience with watching a
baseball game was when i was in san
diego
a whale's vagina i remember that team
was playing against
a team called the cardinals love the
naming you guys have
i guess you were just running out of any
native american related stuff
what are you talking about we ran out of
animals is what we did
so now i don't know what the i don't
know what the that seattle team is
called the crackers
it's some sort of mythical [ __ ]
octopus
uh but basically my friends and i oh
he's making fun of the racist [ __ ] i get
all right
but basically my friends yeah cause you
guys are so [ __ ]
progressive in europe if you got you
know you guys if you're not on the same
currency somebody thinks they're a
superior race over there and tries to
wipe everybody else out every [ __ ] 20
years
uh but basically my friends and i barely
made it to the sixth inning
after which we went to a bar nearby
where the locals were having a karaoke
night
and had no talent for singing at all and
even that was more interesting than the
game
too slow too much repetitiveness and too
much fireworks judging by the
celebration
people might think the uss midway
aircraft carrier they have
just docked after a successful battle
every time somebody hits a ball
anyways loves the love the podcast all
right so you don't like cricket
you don't like cricket or baseball um
yeah there's a lot of people like that
right now if
if the game isn't like i mean if you go
to a wnb if you go to a [ __ ] nba game
every time there's a stoppage of play
they have tumblers and djs and all kinds
of [ __ ] [ __ ] going on
um i don't know
i hope they're not shooting off
fireworks every time something happens
in baseball now
i know that i know they do [ __ ] with
like the scoreboard and they try to
crank it up and make it really [ __ ]
loud
um it's a real we're in a really bad
time right now for live sports
uh yeah i don't know i don't
know that it's gonna come back
uh all right a word for new segment dear
monsieur
fire crutch i am a long time listener
from england and love your show
yada yada me fire crutch that's how we
should have said over the years i have
heard you talk about how you're learning
to speak french on and off i do
uh for the last few weeks you've been
talking about the strange feeling of
regret about
things you wish you said at the time but
didn't think of it until it's too late
well i thought you would like to know
that the french have a fantastic phrase
for this
i remember it as it's maybe my favorite
french phrase
as i spent most of my life suffering
from the same annoying problem
the spiri lespire a spear i don't want
to say a spiri
esprit lesbri de les galler
the spirit of the stairs
ah the spirit of the staircase
literally the meaning the spirit of the
staircase i'll let wikipedia explain
this name for the phenomenon comes from
the french encyclopedias and philosopher
dennis de roth's description of such a
situation in his paradox
sir the comedian paradox of the comedian
during a dinner at the home of statesman
jacques necker negr
i remember uh was made to
a remark was made to dear deira which
led him
left him speechless at the time because
he explains a sensitive man such as
myself
overwhelmed by the argument leveled
against him becomes confused
and doesn't come to himself again until
at the bottom of the stairs
um
anyway it's a bunch of [ __ ] here in
french do i remember a lot of these
words
once i get past the instrument exam i'm
gonna i'm gonna pick this [ __ ] back up
again
in this case the bottom of the stairs
refers to the architecture of the kind
of
uh hotel or uh mansion to which
dieter rot had been invited in such
houses the reception rooms
were on the estas
noble one floor above the ground floor
to have
reached the bottom of the stairs means
definitively left the gathering seems
like this
was pissing off the french long before
us idiots figured it out
i hope this adds a new phrase to your
vocabulary that you can mutter to
yourself
or maybe they were [ __ ] such [ __ ] to
each other they came up with this phrase
uh that you can mutter it to yourself to
starve off the internal rage ps check
out dean martin's
version of gentle gentle on my mind
as it puts a strangely positive spin on
the lyrics
like dean was happy to not see her again
oh okay oh the glenn campbell song
yeah well dean was the coolest [ __ ]
ever all right let's wrap this up here
um things i should have said
hey billy mozzarella legs uh i've been
listening to the podcast for a long time
and a big fan
i have my own i should have said this
story from when i was 18 working at a
golf course look at this and how old is
he now he's still thinking about it
i worked at a fairly high end golf
course in vancouver
even wrote it out for me i was one of
the bag boys who greeted you when you
showed up
and got your clubs set up on your cart i
did that job
part of the job was for us to take out
take note of the tee sheet
so when players arrived and gave their
tea time we could recall the name
without referring back to the tea sheet
made us look good well one day a guy was
walking up from the parking lot
and i walk over to greet him and get his
bag i say hey how are you
what time are you teeing off he replies
10 40. i say
it's i say perfect it's booked under mr
smith he goes i can't remember the last
name
the t sheet gave the first name and the
last name of the person who booked
he quickly replies that's actually dr
smith
and then proceeded to lecture me how he
spent 10 years in medical schools
uh oh that he didn't he hadn't spent 10
years in medical school to be called
mister
ah this guy needs to marry that [ __ ]
colorado chick
now having some family members who have
gone through medical school i know
they only spent eight years in school i
wish i could have said isn't medical
school only eight years and just left it
at that oh that would have been great
i still think about that encounter and
many other things i wish
i could tell him now as as always go
[ __ ] yourself yeah isn't it always eight
years
and did you go to medical school so you
could exaggerate it to somebody half
your [ __ ] age that's putting your bag
of clubs
all right if you were athletic you'd be
playing a sport
enjoy your activity for the next [ __ ]
three hours you [ __ ]
um hey bill
bill should be the next batman burr i
don't know about that i play a villain
though
uh back in the day my high school had a
batshit crazy christian group that swept
through all the grades
with people active i could be the next
lex luther
um through all the grades of people
actively recruiting students while being
very secretly
secretive about what actually happens at
the meetings including towards parents
um wow that's crazy
probable kid [ __ ] aside the thing
that really pissed me off
was one of the one of these when one of
these [ __ ] spoke in class about how
one of my favorite bands at the time
ramstein should be banned from the
school because even though it is in
russian
you can clearly hear them calling
children to satan
etc i just popped in my headphones
and got on with it but to this day i
wish i said
that's amazing that you speak russian
but more amazing
since they are a german band you [ __ ]
cheers and go [ __ ] yourself
i know i know but you don't say it
and that's why we have this segment
called what i should have said
it'll haunt you for the rest of your
life what was said dear billy chunky
trunks
[ __ ] you oh that's so true
this is a story from eighth grade we had
a health teacher
who was a complete scumbag let's call
him mr g
now this is eighth grade so we're 12
years old this guy
a grown-ass man would flirt with the
girls in class
[Music]
can't stress scumbag enough 12 years old
ah there was always that teacher that
you know
flirted with the high school chicks that
was bad enough
oh my god so a few weeks before
christmas that year mr g
was involved in a car accident while
inebriated great
he was not driving but was drunk i know
this is a fact because my dad and
brothers are volunteer firemen are
responding to this accident
during the extradition of mr g and his
friends from the car
mr g was throwing empty beer bottles at
the firemen telling them to leave
my dad and brothers tell me this because
they know i can't stand him
i tell people at school and it gets
around school and gets back to mr g
uh oh you were talking out of school
mr g confronts us in class one day goes
on a rant saying he wasn't drunk blah
blah blah
he goes on to say that the speedometer
only said 45.
a quiet kid in class named blake says
from the back of the class
that's what the speedometer looks like
when you're drunk
we all died laughing the look on his
face was priceless
he held blake after class but no
detention or anything
i still remember it to this day i'm 34
now
still one of the funniest things i ever
heard thanks for the laughs
during a really shitty uh year yeah this
is uh
oh what was said oh that's great
well i gotta think of those you know
it's funny
i didn't have too many of those
in my life even growing up like i would
think of comebacks and [ __ ]
sometimes i would just fall on the knife
and get detention on purpose just to get
the laugh
um but i don't i don't think
yeah i had the typical comedian
upbringing
where people always got the best of me
then i'd walk away oh that's what i
should have said god i'm so stupid
all right that's the podcast to
everybody uh half of four
happy fourth of july weekend to you even
if you're not in this country you still
get a fourth of july
why not celebrate it there's got to be
some loophole that you can come up
you know you can come up with i identify
as american
therefore i'm taking a three-day weekend
on july 4th
you know why do they get that holiday
and we don't
that's it go [ __ ] yourselves and i'll
check in on you on thursday